Germany now there is a place that is
along had a problem with the far right
and a new report from the country's
equivalent of MI5 has discovered that
right-wing extremism is the greatest
threat to German democracy it also
identified as many as 14 000 violent
right-wing extremists living there
now you may recall that late last year
25 people were arrested on suspicion of
plotting to overthrow the government the
majority of them were members of
something known as the reichsberger
movement those who reject the authority
and legitimacy of the German State and
seek to ignore replace or even overthrow
it
now the Resurgence of extremist politics
in a country perhaps most associated
with the rise and spread of fascism is
obviously worrying so too the growth of
extremism being witnessed in other parts
of Europe including the UK
but what's not immediately obvious to me
at least is what is fueling this
extremist Resurgence let alone what can
be done about it
welcome to the Daily I'm Neil Patterson
cars on the table this has to have been
possibly one of the most surreal
experiences I've had in the last year
Siobhan Robbins is Skye's Europe
correspondent so I was investigating the
right wing within Germany and as part of
that I had heard about this guy who was
calling himself the king of Germany he'd
created his own
Kingdom and so I got in contact with
them and we decided to go and have a
chat we went down to the kingdom which
is about two hours outside Berlin so
this is the kingdom
well it's just the village
so I drove up to the gates and there was
basically a corrugated Iron Gate painted
in green like a kind of forest scene and
on the outside it said Kingdom of
Germany hello when I got into the drive
there was a little desk set up and I was
asked to fill out some information so
that I could get a visa and this is my
ID for a Visa please because of course I
was visiting from outside the kingdom
and so I was had to have a one-day visa
to get in so I presented my identity got
the Visa and then went into this very
unassuming building to wait for this
King
how do I
address you
do you have a title do we what do we say
then king of Germany so I say your
majesty
so yeah I guess give me a little tour of
the kingdom of your kingdom so basically
his idea is hello that from around a
decade ago he decided to start the
kingdom of Germany as they've called it
which is a group now of around just over
5 000 people and they essentially don't
accept the elected government and the
current system within Germany so they've
created their own kingdom which has its
own rules they've created their own ID
so he's got his own special passport
he's changed his name so when he flies
within Germany he flies as king Peter
the first they have their own banking
system and he showed me they've got old
silver coins and also they're going to
roll out some banknotes as well if other
people in Germany accept it he would
like to see the kingdom of Germany
basically take over the whole of Germany
as we know it so that everyone living in
Germany would be part of the Kingdom
you see he's incredibly Charming I'm
just wondering if he's entirely the full
Shilling I mean you can't just buy a
patch of land stick up a corrugated
friends and call it your kingdom
otherwise frankly I'd have done that 20
years ago well I asked him these
questions and he's quite clear that this
isn't some sort of crackpot idea in his
mind this is an idea to make Society
work better so he claims people who are
within the kingdom if they work for the
kingdom then they get their food for
free for example for free oh so they can
come and get the food from yeah
[Music]
also gasoline for free car for free rent
for free he claims the current system in
Germany is totally unfair that the
monetary system is unfair and so he's
trying to create this alternative but of
course you can imagine that someone
who's declaring their own State and
saying actually we'd like to see the
current government dissolved in our
state put in doesn't play that highly on
the views of the authorities within
Germany so he says that he has been
under surveillance and certainly is part
of a report about extremism and domestic
potential domestic threats within
Germany the kingdom of Germany is on
that and they are being monitored
because of the fact that they've said
they've created their Kingdom but also
because they're being held together with
a group a sort of quite disparate group
within Germany which are called rice
burger and essentially rice Burger as a
whole are lots of different groups but
together they all believe that the
current system is wrong and some of them
believe that basically
the current government is illegal and
that the German State Should revert to
how it was before the war so that they
want to get rid of post-war Germany as
we now know it okay I can understand why
you might describe someone who wants to
secede from your country as an extremist
I'm not entirely certain why one would
describe them as far right so the thing
about the rice Burger is it's not just
the kingdom which the domestic
authorities in German count in this
group there are around 23 000 rice
Burger within Germany and just before
Christmas we saw a group of people being
arrested 25 people as part of raids to
foil what the authorities say was a rice
Burger plot to violently overthrow the
government in Germany now this wasn't
connected to the kingdom of Germany or
King Peter King Peter is very clear that
none of his followers or he would
support any type of violent coup to take
over the government but it was part of
this Riceberg of movement and as part to
this report they've said around 10
percent of people who believe in this
rice Burger are potentially violent and
that's why they're watching okay look I
mean the figure of 14 000 violent
right-wing extremists is clearly
concerning but I'd submit that more
concerning than that is sitting in the
reichstag at the moment you have
far-right extremist politicians now of
course they would say they are neither
violent nor divisive but surely it is
still concerning to see politicians with
far-right views sitting in a parliament
so closely associated with fascism yes
so one of the groups which is causing
concern particularly within the left
wing is the FD alternative for Germany
party which has 78 seats in Parliament
and is elements of it are being watched
by the security services so for example
one of what we call within that party
one of the right-wing poster boys has
been charged with using a slogan which
was only used by elements of the Nazi
party and certainly I spoke to a man
called Solomon Malik who lives in East
Germany and he claims that he has been a
victim of far-right extremism which he
believes that elements like the afd are
stoking so he's been trying to build a
mosque for 10 years and part of the
delay to that is because he said that
workmen who are trying to come and work
on the site were being threatened being
told that they shouldn't go and work for
Muslims that one day he turned up and
that there was a pig's head on a stake
and pork scattered around the site that
he's received numerous death threats as
well and he believes that there really
is a concerning rise in right wing
thoughts in Germany do you think there
would be a lot of support if there was a
coup that installed a right-wing
government yes there will be you think
there is yes there will be there is why
because they see that this is the
solution we saw the pictures in USA the
fact she can't rule out the risk is
because just in December we saw these 25
arrests which are allegedly connected to
a plot to violently overthrow the
government and to violently invade
Parliament here in Germany
and that's why the authorities here are
so Vigilant they said that right-wing
extremism is the biggest threat
domestically to democracy in Germany
that's how seriously they're taking it
we must never underestimate the
murderous danger posed by right-wing
extremism and right-wing terrorism
that's the conclusion drawn by Germany's
interior Minister following the security
service report which identified that
there were almost 39 000 right-wing
extremists now that is a figure up by
more than five thousand in just a year
[Music]
but why Julia Ebner is an academic
specializing in radicalization and
right-wing extremism and the author of
going mainstream how extremists are
taking over unfortunately this is
exactly what I've also observed in my
own research I've also done a number of
undercover investigations into far-ad
extremist movements including in Germany
and I've seen that the language there
has become more aggressive and that the
membership numbers have really risen to
to unseen levels especially the pandemic
but also the Ukraine war and the ongoing
economic and energy crisis and inflation
crisis all of that has caused a lot of
frustrations within the German
population especially when it comes to
the German politicians so all of this
has really widened societal divisions
and it also has also caused a very high
support for Germany's far-right populist
party the IFD you mentioned a number of
reasons there Julia for the rise in in
extremism you mentioned you know the
Ukraine conflicts obviously covered I
mean there would be those sitting
outside of Germany that would have
immediately thought well presumably
Germany's past Germany's fascist past
has quite a lot to do with as well it
does also play a role certainly there is
still a taboo in terms of speaking about
nationalism speaking about a kind of
Pride national pride is still something
that is not really socially acceptable
and that has been of concern for many
Germans who wanted to take pride in
their country in their Origins and
that's also something that the far right
has been able to tap into and
unfortunately there have also been of
course a number of crises where Germany
has been particularly hard hit in the
past the so-called migration Refugee
crisis a few years ago but also the kind
of security crisis that we saw with the
rise of Isis and a number of attacks
jihadist attacks that Germany has faced
then that meant that anti-migration and
C xenophobic ideas could really
penetrate the mainstream on the basis of
that one has to presume that these views
are being shared most prominently online
that this is where the spread of these
ideologies is most active it it
certainly is and Germany is I would say
based on on my research is one of the
top countries when it comes to
Alternative media outlets and citizens
so-called citizen journalism
where a lot of these alternative media
Outlets position themselves in
opposition to the so-called mainstream
media which is of course also a term
that has then closely been associated
with the old Nazi term Luna which is now
increasingly used by forehead extremists
today in Germany the lying press
basically that actually often promote
conspiracy myths and dangerous
narratives and often a lot of
disinformation about migrants about in
general minority communities and about
leading politicians that has really also
further Amplified the Dynamics that
we're seeing
talk to me a little then about the
reichsberger movement because it seems
fascinating to me that there is this
loose Collective of individuals who feel
that the state doesn't represent them to
the extent that they wish to rise up
some of them to overthrow the Democratic
constitutional Norms of a country like
Germany where does this come from
because it does look associated with
that which I would more typically call
the far right the fascist the racist the
you know the homophobic and so on but
but it also seems slightly distinct to
that as well it is it is there's a
strong overlap with uh the The Wider
farad extremist Community but as you say
it's a network of mainly anti-democratic
anti-institutional extremists or
Sovereign citizens who don't accept the
Constitution the German Constitution and
who partly would also turn to violence
in order to overthrow the current
government of course not all of them can
be seen as violent but number of Iceberg
or German Sovereign citizens has also
strongly risen in recent years and it's
now it's no longer a fringe phenomenon
it's really in the tens of thousands
some of them just refuse to pay taxes
but others might even consider resorting
to violence there have been plots to
overthrow the the German government but
even that is of course quite delusional
and would be extremely unrealistic but
as we've seen with the U.S capital riots
even if it's an unsuccessful plot to
storm a democratic institution or to to
enter a democratic institution that can
trigger a whole Mass phenomenon of
people prefer to potentially being
inspired by that but also causing a lot
of Terror and a lot of fear not just
within policy circles but also within
the wider population so I wouldn't
underestimate um to what extent they can
influence the overall debate and the the
atmosphere in the country I suppose the
key difference evidence between England
the UK and Germany is that at this point
we do not have political representation
of those far-right organizations in the
mainstream it still exists on the
fringes why has it been tolerated in the
mainstream in Germany
that is a very good question in in the
German mainstream I would say that
because the Centrist parties have
distanced themselves from these
ideologies that there was a
representative vacuum that could be
filled by the alternative for Germany
but even the alternative to far and
populist party the alternative for
Germany radicalized a lot over the last
10 years since it was founded you could
really observe that the language is now
flirting with conspiracy myths with
extremist ideologies that are becoming
much more visible they've of course
always been kind of embedded within the
party's overall thinking and and
approach but they are the party wasn't
originally founded actually as an as an
anti-eu party so not so different from
kind of ukip's goals and what we've seen
in the UK is also that of course within
the conservative party there has been a
bit more of kind of taking up some of uh
some of the audiences that would have
otherwise potentially voted for French
parties I would say that the
conservative party in the UK has has
sometimes also flirted with these
audiences kind of using anti-migration
rhetoric sometimes even giving a little
wink to conspiracy myth communities and
that is something that has helped them
to at least keep out the more radical
extremist parties who've not really
managed to get into power but overall it
still tells us something about the wider
societal atmosphere which might still be
one where extremism can Thrive and can
actually become mainstreamed I suppose
the issue is that you know whereas in
your mind's eye we may believe fascists
to be you know shaven-headed jack-booted
idiots these days you're as likely to
see them dressed in an expensive suit
you know speaking in well the German
Parliament
definitely it's uh it's been quite
um quite an experience also in my
undercover investigations that sometimes
I could not really tell apart who the
who the extremists actually were and
that even applies to the most extreme of
extremists the neo-nazis were no longer
recognizable in their clothing where
there's been a whole new trend of
rebranding and making sure that they're
seen as as socially acceptable and this
representative of the overall population
so they can also attract new members who
are average citizens
some of the parallels we were just
discussing there between England and
Germany frankly you could you could
provide plenty of evidence that there
are similar activity in large parts of
the United States amongst the Republican
movement tell me a little bit about the
states and and Europe the U.S is of
course a very good example of a
radicalization of politics that we could
observe especially since the rise to
power of of trump uh in 2016 where it's
almost as if the Republicans have
forgotten what the party stands for
because Trump doesn't really represent
any form of conservatism anymore it's
more it's it's much more radical than
that so it's it's interesting how also
the attitudes within the population have
of course changed um over the years and
have become partly more radical we've
seen that in surveys for example
conducted by the University of Chicago
that showed the support the high support
rates within the U.S populations for the
the insurrectionist movement behind the
U.S capital riots so there is a question
question of what radicalized first the
politicians or the voters I wonder
however though I mean through your
research you will have seen I'm sure
evidence that these groups in different
parts of the world but but sharing some
kind of central core ideas they are
talking to each other they're
communicating with each other and they
are advising each other
there's absolutely a very strong
International
collaboration or even Coalition that has
formed on the far right but also among
hyper-conservative players so um
Evangelical movements in the US that
have been funding activities in Europe
campaigns against the lgbtq community
against abortion rights we've seen the
first consequences of that also showing
up in European politics and on the other
side of the Atlantic and that's of
course very concerning
my thanks to Julia and Siobhan and that
is your lot for today's edition of The
Daily with me with Neil Patterson
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett with Alex Eden and Amy Lakin our
editor is Adam G